I see a huge amount of Joffrey Baratheon
in Richard a second both of them boy
Kings both of them not really learn it
in in the ways of being a king
absolutely drunk on their own majesty
right back to Lord Frey and command him
to send Robb Stark's head I'm going to
serve it to Sansa at my wedding feast
good joke if we did not mean it isn't it
richard ii became king cos his father
died before his grandfather died i
should have spent more time with you
show me how to be a man he's not been
around his father he's never been in
military situations they're coming
ashore they're too many he's a brat
kneel before your king I said kneel
richard ii is a really spiteful vengeful
King and you see that bubbling up in
Joffrey so please your grace lady
something is very tight no wait here the
purple wedding this dramatic death of
Joffrey which were also cheering when it
happens on the screen and historically I
thought you can look at some comparisons
quite early in English Middle Ages when
Eustace of bellowing who is the heir to
the throne under King Stephen died quite
suddenly one day at a feast Eustace was
eating lamprey pie and he choked to
death some people said it was poison
other people said Eustace died of
apoplexy he was so furious with his
father for signing away the throne to
somebody else there are these incidents
in history where people do die
mysteriously but your sisters anyone I
know who actually died choking in a
feast so that was probably the
inspiration for the mode of Joffrey's
death can I talk to you about Joffrey I
have never been so moved
rated by a body on television in my
entire life
he's unsettling and hateable on so many
different levels so you've got this tiny
psychopath born of incest with a
tendency for woman beaten and sexually
perverted malice and worse probably in
my opinion and all of this he was
responsible for the death of one of the
direwolf in the first series my theory
is he somebody that you went to school
with you know there might be something
to that I think he's about five or six
people they went to school with we both
face I like a pretty Joffrey is a
classic bully in many ways and he's very
full of himself and he's incredibly he's
spoiled I mean he was raised without
limits and he's got two fathers neither
of which has ever really given him much
of what you would call fatherly
attention or discipline I think in some
senses he's still trying to impress his
fathers we're being very fortunate in
our actor I mean Jack Gleeson who is by
the way the nicest kid in the world and
he's terrific and he's doing such an
amazing job that I think people are
threatening him on the street and
wanting to come up and slap him and
wouldn't be Society gets assaulted
[Laughter]
[Music]
Joffre I do a lot of in all societies
and
and cultures I'm afraid around the world
and I forget things to remember about
Joffrey is that he's uh you know and
this is particularly true of course in
that in the fall season is a 13 year old
kid we played this model in the TV show
of course the Jack lees and a wonderful
accurately portrayed image is even older
than the character were supposed to be
you know you really don't want to give a
thirteen-year-old kid absolute power
own life and death over everyone around
them that's that's a general rule
and in terms of you know looking inward
I mean even a character like Joffrey
there's some of me in it you know what
if I had been you know as a 13 year old
kid god where are the kids they hate it
if I had had the power to kill them I
could easily say making a couple of the
school bullies back at their majority
fight to the death
we all have this stuff inside this is
something I try to get at when I read
about my characters you know fantasy and
I and I love fantasy and particularly
look they are talking but I think these
set up bad templates for the lesser
writers would follow with the whole
motion of the Dark Lord rising and
quoting all the evil creatures to em and
you know there are no redeeming
characteristics to probable support for
ox or dragons in antonius world they're
purely creatures of malice and
destruction and supportiveness good
versus evil is a theme for all kinds of
literature and has been some people been
telling stories and will continue the
beautiful people will be telling stories
but I don't think that the battle
between good and evil is necessarily for
between me you know one group of noble
heroes on one side have nice white
clothes or weight maps or whatever and
on the other side a bunch of really ugly
guys who wear black is no bad
and the battle between good and evil is
for within the individual human heart
between all of us every day and every
year and people who do noble and heroic
things on Tuesday they do something vile
and selfish on Wednesday
our lives are sequences of choices that
we're constantly having to wrestle with
and that's kind of what I try to get at
it in that you've tried with some of
that without some people pick up on this
I know that all but at the moment when
when droppers actually dying
I tried to give a instead of pathos
there were a period who's watching it
happening realizes he's seeing a 13 year
old kid in terror choking to death
before his eyes as generally lost and
the general Glee what
unless it's there I tried to work in
that little Grayson